de la voiture tombée à plus de 5 mètres
en contrebas de la chaussée seul un bout
de pare-chocs et visible cette longue
trace indique l'endroit où le conducteur
aurait perdu le contrôle de son véhicule
cet autre automobiliste n'a pas été
témoin direct de l'accident mais c'est
lui qui a donné l alerte
j'ai constaté des feuilles sur la route
un petit bout de carénage et 1
les traces de pneus donc comme je suis
passé une heure avant ça n'était pas
j'ai fait nuit et tendre un chemin pour
me proposer
et là j'ai entendu un petit peu crée
donc deux personnes qui étaient dans
l'eau que j'ai sorti de l'eau pour
sécuriser et m et après les conflits
immédiatement trois personnes étaient à
bord de son sorti indemme point ces deux
longues minutes dans le véhicule immergé
les secours ont tenté en vain de
réanimer sur place la troisième
occupante
âgée de 31 ans elle est décédée avant
son arrivée à l'hôpital d'auxerre
c'est le troisième accident quelques
mois sur cet axe départemental entre un
poignet gurgy c'est un sujet sur lequel
il faut qu'on garde précisément parce
que aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de risque
en vue qui nous amène à aller
directement sur ce cours d'eau et donc
chuté dans l'eau en sais rien ce que le
conducteur a dit c'est qu'il avait perdu
contrôle de son véhicule
il est vrai qu'après vous fait constater
par vous même que la chute est quand
même plus que rapide
du coup c'est sûr que je veux dire même
en allant peut vite forcément il se
retrouve tout de suite en bas une
enquête devra déterminer les causes
exactes de cet accident
depuis janvier 2015 26 personnes ont
trouvé la mort sur les routes de l'yonne